five-minute crafts made five of my veins
pop out of my head the last time i
watched it let's see if they've improved
this time around
headache from reading a book maybe you
need gla
okay my god they go into the 3d effects
of it what are they showing blood lots
of blood neurons okay nerve endings are
active can you imagine my patient walked
in with a headache and i'm just like
oh my gosh
well i don't even have any hair right
now see i love it that they don't make
any claims that's how they get away with
it you assume it's a headache it says
nerve fibers activating which is kind of
true like any time you touch yourself or
move nerve fibers are activating and
then she smiles and you think the
headache is gone but they never said
that she had a headache we're the ones
interpreting their art wrong suffering
from heartburn she's gonna roll over to
the other side and they're gonna say
that's the better side to sleep on we'll
see
[Music]
three years undergrad four years medical
school three years residency five years
practicing medicine i could have just
done this it's gonna change the way you
practice i'm gonna why we should just
close med schools and just tell people
to watch five minute crafts because
apparently it's that simple there's
legitimate things you can do to treat
acid reflux raise the head of your bed
somewhat so you stay like this and
gravity will keep the acid down don't
eat so close to bedtime at least two
hours prior don't ingest things that
create more acid secretion like caffeine
especially at bedtime see these are
things that actually work that we tell
our patients not random things like
rotate to the other side and that
prevents gastric yeah what about if you
have a hiatal hernia look that one up
oh those blisters are brutal second skin
that's the way to go
that hit me unexpected i was like what
kind of tape is that and then bacon just
pops up on top oh my god can you imagine
the fungus that's gonna grow on that can
you imagine you're at work and there's
just like bacon falling off behind you
like people are gonna have questions it
was a hot summer day because of the
friction maybe you cook it maybe you eat
it
that's the joke that's the joke in there
get some second skin it's inexpensive
basically it decreases friction on the
area it falls off after a few days you
could shower with it all that good stuff
um mom is asking the child where he got
this pill from maybe that's not what's
up
he doesn't want it
he had a marshmallow we got like an
exacto knife here mom's performing
surgery she sticks a pill into the gummy
bear need to be careful with stuff like
this because some medications you can't
chew and you must swallow whole so if
you give your child that pill in there
and your child choose it that could be a
big problem no q-tips in the ears also
what kind of ear works is that with some
powdery earwax hydrant frogs oh
okay wow i'm touched that was a good
video you don't have to do it like that
there's drops that you could put in
yours that contain hydrogen peroxide
like debrox drops you got to make sure
that you don't have any other issues
going on when you are using that it
basically melts the wax so it comes out
nicely out of your ear canal i like it
decent advice
what is this high-end swing and where do
these high-end swings exist that looks
nice braided high-end oh nice look at
that wood fresh wood mommy don't stop
how about mommy puts away her tick-tock
for a second and pays attention to her
child i knew she was gonna create some
ridiculous thing
[Music]
the purpose of you standing next to your
child is not just for you to do this
back and forth but it's to bond with
your child to have fun in the moment and
you know what to be there in case the
child falls what are you gonna do when
you pull it a little bit too hard the
child falls backwards okay kid getting
pushed around in a little ferrari truck
save the drama for your llama 10 out of
10 for the cute poster oh you know what
happens when you get back pain quidditch
there is no way they said grab a stick
to push your child around in a car as a
real hack she couldn't use her foot and
i like the kids bulls pat it looks like
the [ __ ] i came to the united states
and i was like a little kid
okay there's a fake doctor with a really
fake medical background behind them and
there's a microscope
plastic microscope on the desk and a
band-aid oh child doesn't want a
band-aid but we're gonna draw hearts on
it wow that's design hacks right there
wow look at those designs high quality
design it's like when girls go to get a
manicure or guys for that matter and
they get all those like intricate
designs and they're like go check out my
pikachu nail design i'm like yeah but
check out my band-aid with hearts
five-minute crafts edition okay nervous
about a meeting nervous about a meeting
very nervous about a meeting brushing
your hair for five minutes helps you
cope with anxiety did they just create
an ocd type coping mechanism potentially
she will no longer feel comfortable
walking into social settings unless
she's combed her hair how else would i
deal with that psychology oh is that a
service provided by family medicine
doctors and mental health providers
worldwide okay hanging out get sand in
your eye okay spill the water bottle
into a bowl
dip your face in water okay do they
really say get something in your eye use
water to get it out can you imagine
getting mud on their body and then going
to a shower to wash it off and say heck
no i mean that's what we just witnessed
she just poured out the water bottle
that she spent five minutes spitting
into with her bacteria pink eye is gonna
happen here could be bacterial
conjunctivitis and it could be even
worse you could get a corneal abrasion
which can lead to infection if there's a
lot of bacteria in there look at this
dangerous misinformation cute little
baby baby don't want milk baby wants a
watermelon this is a medical danger and
this needs to be corrected asap you do
not put straws into a watermelon that
has seeds and give it to a child so they
can inhale one of the seeds and choke
see that's cute right but then mom walks
away and the baby sucks on the opposite
straw and inhales the seed
full-on choking hazard here good job
five-minute crafts yes i'm angry okay
child runs up with a band-aid upset
because she doesn't want to take it off
wet it oh wow life hack people didn't
know that sticky substances come off
with water wow
i needed a youtube video to learn that
one because i didn't know tape was
susceptible to water it's like a fire
pokemon
b cgi b that's funny i just said four
letters and everyone knows what i'm
talking about the cgib
oh and it left it's like little stinger
in there
oh what do we got here who has that
device who has that device on them
this cgi on this is top notch hey mom
he's washing hands child is washing
hands no soap i guess this is a common
issue
jelly soap oh she's gonna make soap in
the shape of legos that's kind of cool
really cool actually like this is the
only one i would probably try i just
don't know how effective it is i guess
whatever's in that jelly soap i hope is
good yeah i'm with it i like this one
okay they finally got a dr mike's stamp
of approval okay sleep little baby sleep
sleep sleep oh mom doesn't know how to
take off a hair tie
oh she's gonna put lemon
what is she gonna do to essential oil
why did she put a scent
what kind of chemicals did she just put
on her child's hair that ate through
rubber and why was she unable to just
take them off who's gonna go and
purchase that product and then when
their child falls asleep sneak into the
room and start applying chemicals to
their children's hair want some water a
child doesn't want water says ao to the
water let's put some lemon in the water
chewy candy and olive oil whipped cream
sprinkles again with tiny inhalable
objects why are they trying to kill
children maybe those are a little bit
too big to go into the straw but still
why even risk it especially if they
start melting and they get smaller yeah
if you put lemon in water it makes lemon
water and it becomes tastier you didn't
need all the other stuff okay mom's
washing hands child runs in also wants
to wash hands good teaching opportunity
to sing happy birthday while you foamy
up your hands we're gonna put soap the
bugs will be pushed away from it but see
the soap shouldn't go in there it should
go on her hand if anything you could get
one of those like kits they're
relatively inexpensive where you put all
this like stuff on your hands and then
you shine a light on it and you see the
stuff is all over your hands and then
unless you wash very thoroughly you
don't get it all off that's a better
teaching experiment than whatever's
happening here okay some blackheads aka
closed comey don'ts floss no no this is
a bad trick don't do this oh what what
the heck is happening is that a hot glue
gun give it a chance okay what are we
doing here we're creating a
flossing kit their hack for blackheads
is to 3d print a handheld nose flosser
and rip your skin off
wash your face wash your face wash your
face
dark armpits dark armpits can be caused
by a condition known as type 2 diabetes
so maybe you should go see your doctor
and not make a lemon flower juice potion
for it there's hormonal conditions that
cause darkening of your armpits maybe
you should legitimately see your doctor
and be give that recommendation
five-minute crafts because you could
just have hidden their actual medical
condition
milk your feet this is for the foot
fetish people that's who watch this a
slow pouring of the honey across the
feet with the massage piece look if
you're into this cool but medically like
it's not that serious yeah right i buy
that ftc can we get in here on this
ridiculous blackheads
again with the concoction dude they just
pour random stuff that are labeled
healthy into dishes and then act like it
helps like seaweed why is seaweed going
no no that's not gonna work dry skin
same person because you put the seaweed
on your skin with the green tea mixing
the petals it's a very pretty concoction
it's it's a honey petal
[Music]
so arbitrary
check out my video of everything that
went wrong when i went on tour it
actually shows some bits of the show
very funny worth a watch bears in it as
always stay happy and healthy unlike
those five minute crafts
[Music]